names Max Lombardi and I've been an
agent for ten goddamn years you want to
know what it's like let me tell you
about it the Lombardi tails
[Music]
I'm really sorry about all this
I knew he was in trouble as soon as
Barnes shot your daughter
I quit crying she'll be fine
he's a lousy shot anyway
I'm really sorry about your dog
I mean if they're by my leg but I guess
it wouldn't have done that if I hadn't
be beating you with that lamp Hey good
news there the lamp still works little
duct tape will be good as new those
ropes too tight sorry
I'd loosen them but we don't want you
getting loose and trying to escape
there's been enough screw-ups tonight
don't you think guys should be pissed
that is your neighbor [ __ ] switched
the house numbers must have known we was
on to him you want to know what this is
about huh what the hell in like you'll
remember any of this tomorrow
see a few months ago there was some
murders yeah you ran a bottom you know
skinned alive that's a bunch of [ __ ]
right there you ever skinned somebody
alive they wriggle everywhere now look
who you've done never throw up when
you're gagged here let me clean your
mouth now you scream we're gonna have to
break another finger okay there you go
that's good light in the bucket and now
the gag goes back on and you still got
eight good fingers you see how that
works and not just kidding about the
finger out of just shove the gag back on
it you've suffered enough you know so
where was I uh
oh yeah skinning people life hard as
hell that bit was made up by the papers
sounds a hell a lot more exciting now I
cut their throats first then skin them
anyway 20 years back there was another
case kind of like this back east
there's a few folks who have talked
about it but they don't think there's a
connection on account that the guy was
caught but
that's out the [ __ ] said he needed to
eat the skin to live how does he end up
dying malnutrition even though he gets
three meals a day so we look into it
and the guy had a kid who moved out here
yeah your neighbor so we come in do some
checking up and once we did it came
pretty clear he did it unfortunately
looks like he got wind of us and skipped
out with the last little screw you in
the bargain so we got guys tearing up
his place to figure out where he wet
I'll we'll find them don't worry he's
sloppy and screw up eventually anyway
get comfy we got someone coming here is
gonna make you forget everything that
happened tomorrow morning this will seem
like it was just a botched robbery we'll
even say you what to look like a hero
saved your family how's that oh by the
way uh has the run around here seems
like a nice neighborhood
you